Olá no vídeo anterior Este sou eu que
fiz uma chamada de FaceTime com os trem
da deep web tudo isto para comprar uma
caixa misteriosa verdadeira é
o Ok como é que eu entrego essa caixa
não sei só gostava de saber se a Caixa
cheia mesmo chegar a casa
E aí
é
um qualquer coisa ali dentro de forma
muito branco um
[Música]
o Olá pessoal vou para aí tá
Olá
pessoal aqui quem fala aqui sejam muito
bem vindos a mais um vídeo Finalmente um
vídeo novo aqui no canal pessoal gostei
que vocês estavam ansiosos Eu também
estava muito ansioso pessoal mas nós
vemos agora para uma nova casa portanto
eu tenho tantas pela mudança é transição
toda tem dado muito trabalho tem sido
uma loucura mas finalmente eu consegui
estabilizar aqui um pouquinho Portanto
vamos voltar aos vídeos aqui neste canal
aqui e por que que eu tenho nesse canal
porque não segundo canal o canal de
jogos eu até te passar alguns vídeos
mais regularmente do que aqui então se
vocês não seguem pessoal tá aí Dá trem
2.0 só acompanharem lá até o armário do
Fox e do Zé raposas eu tenho aqui no
estúdio portanto se quiserem ver um
pouquinho a casa depois até posso
mostrar ok mas hoje o foco vai ser na
nossa boneca assombrada da deep web que
vocês tanto faz eu já não posso um vídeo
sobre o assunto há mais ou menos um mês
Ok porque foi nessa fase que eu comecei
a mudança mas até hoje ainda recebemos
comentários a perguntar onde é que está
boneca assombrada dar quê Porque é que
tu não continuaste a investigar a caixa
que tu recebeste dá tempo é e eu tenho
aqui a resposta para você e ela está
aqui eu trouxe para casa nova né mas ok
creio nesse vídeo de paraquedas Eu fiz
um vídeo anteriormente é de pular abrir
esta caixa onde os mortos esta boneca da
deep web
e Vejam Só continuar com broca continuar
testador eu desde então nunca mais
pequena Ok e nesse vídeo eu vou pegar
nela vou tentar montar lá vamos ver o
que é que eu descubro sobre a boneca
Porque muitos de vocês também ajudaram
muitos vocês comentaram aí coisas sobre
essa boneca o que poderá ser esta boneca
de que ano Qual a marca qual a origem
dela agora lá ver o que é que você quer
essa boneca chama-se Daisy e ela sobrou
uma pessoa até a morte chamado tons vive
no Brasil e ele quando descobriu o
tentou destruí-la mas dois anos depois
faleceu misteriosamente não daí vocês
também que acham da isso aí tem 180
likes portanto é provável que seja
verdade ok e vamos ver aqui as respostas
ferrou não é feito procura ou não o
Eduardo comenta eu escolho Deus eu
escolho ser amigo de Deus eu também
escolho né vai ter ele demônio lhe dizer
lá no outro comentário interessante ou
lá Dark então eu falei com a minha tia
que trabalha com bonecas há 67 anos e
ela disse que o cabelo foi cozido ou
colado na cabeça por alguém é uma coisa
misterioso e a borracha que está no
pescoço era para segurar a cabeça Ok
Isso já tem percebido espero ter ajudado
peço os buracos no tronco da boneca são
sim de uma caixa de som um que
supostamente estaria nas costas da
boneca ok pessoal Nós também vamos ver
se realmente a boneca tem uma caixa de
som dentro dela e se tiver Espero que
não funcione porque nunca se sabe o som
que pode vir beleza OK de qualquer forma
estiver avariada eu vou tentar arranjar
Ok eu vou tentar consertar mas depois
fica para um futuro vídeo talvez porque
né medo medo apodera-se de mim ok tem
várias respostas este comentário talvez
foi o barulho da Caixa de Música quando
dar que disse que eu vi um barulho bom
eu vou tentar explicar melhor você disse
que aqueles Buraquinhos eram de uma
caixa de música então a caixa de música
deve ter tocado e esse foi o barulho que
o Dark ouviu ele ouviu o barulho no
início do vídeo
já nem me lembro disso Será que a Caixa
de Música está a funcionar pessoal vamos
ver isso hoje outro comentário
interessante Olha aí o quê o Gomes disse
olá Dark pelo meu conhecimento essa
parece-me ser a boneca Marta fabricada
pela troll por volta dos anos 50/60 Isso
é muito específico Além Deste gosto
muito bem nesta altura as bonecas eram
pintadas a mão daí a pintura estar dessa
maneira também era comum o uso de
perucas que eram coladas nas suas
cabeças e eram usados elásticos para
unir as partes dos seus corpos é o que a
boneca tem
com o tempo os elásticos quebram espero
ter ajudado nota-se na parte de trás do
corpo dela estiver marcado troll Então
ela de certeza da minha pequena
investigação e sim existe uma boneca
Marta da trol Como podem ver ela é bem
parecida Mas esta ainda parece muito
mais antiga do que a que eu tenho aqui
portanto eu acho que não seja é que eu
ainda encontrei outra boneca que acho
que foi produzida no Brasil aí no Brasil
é boneca Andinha esta boneca aqui é bem
parecida é muito parecida mesmo e tenho
todo o mecanismo que faz andar as pernas
vocês derem a mão a boneca ela anda
convosco e eu acho que é muito mais
parecida com esta boneca a boneca
Andinha também deve ter sido fabricada
lá por volta dos anos 50/60 então
parece-me muito com essa boneca Apesar
desta boneca estar completamente nova e
a minha estar completamente desfeita
portanto Com certeza que foi alterada
por algum motivo por estar a bastante
velhos de gravada né mas vamos ver
pessoal vamos tentar achar algum algum
código de série e alguma coisa que nos
indique Qual é a marca da boneca
e bora lá só já deixei o bolso like aqui
neste vídeo vamos investigar melhor o
que é que esta boneca tem Vamos colocar
aqui vamos ver tudo código de série se
ela tem algum nome se tem alguma marca
específica que eu possa investigar e
saber melhor sobre esta boneca vamos
descobrir isso hoje bora lá
e assim Olha isso
continua Sombrio como no primeiro dia
ficou um mês aqui em casa sem lhe tocar
Ok Pois é temos que chegar aqui estes
estudos todas essas coisas todas para
que isto parece que tem muita coisa aqui
tipo sei lá no que esses riscos contagem
de dias será que ela teve presa dentro
da caixa não tem isso já sabe que esses
Olha que este prego aqui olha aí também.
Alto
vamos começar pelo corpo
e nós acumulado lá no chão
o
Ok vamos começar pelos braços que são
está parte saiu
e tu temos aqui a nossa primeira peça um
abraço
o Ok está tudo normal tenho cinco dedos
e peixe meu a boneca ter quatro dedos aí
é que eram as caçadoras
e era mesmo o testador lá deles para
atacar o que ela abrisse atacar ela é
que o Mac Olha tu não sabes duvido que
haja alguma coisa de Paranormal aqui ó
mas como eu disse me disse assim ainda
ver
aqui
era só pessoal ó
e
nota-se perfeitamente que tem elásticos
ali dentro e este é um dos arames
repreende nas elástico e forma tipo
agradar os braços penso que seja isso e
não tem aqui nenhuma marca nenhum código
de um registo que identifica a boneca
vamos ver as outras partes do corpo eu
acho que a maioria das vezes e ele
indica nas
E aí
em várias aranhas aqui dentro ó
o bicho aqui dentro Eu não sei se tem
uma hora mas a aranha continua aqui ela
continua aqui olha o número ela vem para
casa agora
sim ou não
hoje eu vou falar né
Desculpa aí pela janela e
e como podem ver para aqui o elástico
estilo acho que têm aspeto bem velho é
bem antigo porque ele já perdeu mais ou
menos a sua elasticidade assim aparecer
o couro sabem estilo acho que é para
sustentar a cabeça e já está todos para
a cidade então se eu quiser montar a
boneca novamente vou ter que colocar
aqui um novo
eu quero voltar a mão tava toda e vamos
ver como é que ela fica OK mas primeiro
talvez tenho que tirar uma daqui né e
aumentar as pernas também garrafas aqui
e tem que uns parafusos aqui
na barriga eu acho que uma caixa de som
já muita gente tempo a comentar isso e
eu também acho e ela tem eu lá dentro
alguma coisa repara
eu não sei se conseguem ver o pessoal
que não dá para ver muito ele qualquer
coisa eu estou a ver tipo um tambor uma
caixa de som mesmo
eu acho que sim se não falar pelo menos
da música qualquer coisa assim
ai acho que
vamos analisar o corpo da nossa boneca
nota-se que ela aqui foi colada com uma
cola especial com qualquer coisa nota-se
que foi aberta talvez a caixa de música
Esteja estragada e alguém tento
consertar e não conseguiu e voltou a
colar a boneca e é por isso que ela vem
desmontada pode ser tudo isso até nos
temos que analisar melhor as coisas ela
tem um pouco de dor portanto já está
aqui há muito tempo
Ah tá sem cabeça há muito tempo meu é
uma por dentro tem um mecanismo muito
estranho eu acho que a mesma caixa de
música é mesma Caixa de Música
encontrei encontrei Calma eu não sei se
dá para tirar os sapatos mas tem aqui o
número de série nos sapatos dela
e aqui diz Kevin mande Toy Produções
making me usa Ok esta boneca do Estados
Unidos ou ontem vídeo do sapato porque
se tá fácil pode não ser dela mas pelo
menos o sapato era Estados Unidos e foi
feito que ele foram lente Toy
se
descobrirmos a origem desta boneca Ok
não comprei umas muito parecidas
E aí sua mãe vai se é muito sinistro eu
vou tentar encontrar aqui a mais
parecida tem o mesmo sapato essa aqui é
bem parecido esta boneca aqui aí
o dela mas depois vou investigar melhor
Ok vamos continuar a investigar o que
tenho aqui dentro agora vou retirar a
festa patinhos dela porque pode
acontecer é ser este sapato ser de outra
boneca feita nesta empresa e colocada
aqui pode ser pode não ser só se eu
encontrar este modelo específico Aí sim
acontecer a certeza mas eu vestido e
depois e bora lá porque é que tem aqui
estarão nesses buracos Porque será que é
para segurar a caixa de música é
eu
não tou a ver a caixa de música tem uma
caixa de ar direto ali estou agora caixa
e uma caixa de música lá dentro olha só
é aquilo é um tambor é uma caixa tá por
isso para alguma forma ali dentro acho
que é só um anel para é só um anel isso
não faz nada tinha qualquer coisa aqui
pessoal
a nota se tinha alguma coisa escrita mas
foi apagada com o celular com
O Bicho Qualquer coisa assim ela deveria
ter aqui o número de série dela umas
coisas fechada estranho porque eles
abriram apagar o número
o visto não
o
burro eu também as pernas não não olha
aqui
em casa trincar a boneca a boneca que
anda a boneca Tumblr ok pessoal isto
confirma a linha de suspeita de ser uma
das Bonecas a boneca Andinha por essa
boneca supostamente quando nós estávamos
a mão e andávamos com a boneca a boneca
andava por si própria e eu me parece que
está acontecendo paga eu te empurrar a
boneca ela anda sozinho ó ela mexe as
pernas não mexer a Cabeça Ela mexe as
pernas portanto ela acordou anda cito a
garota mão dela e puxar a perna vai
andar e a cabeça dela ainda faz isto não
é pior velho mesmo assim ó E aí
o
imaginam a mesma muito sozinha não
sabemos oque estamos aqui o sapato a
boneca os braços vamos ver a cabeça que
também vai ser muito interessante não
tinha estiver ela aqui eu já me esqueci
desta vela
e não nesta tela não vou trocar não
é tem macumba aí sei lá o que queira não
sugere TSE outras brincadeiras já apoio
mas não é
eu não estava é macumbaria não não
mas é que fica mal disso a casa mas
amaldiçoar nós
eu
acabei de fazer muito nojenta porquê que
debaixo é como se tivesse sujo ou sei lá
ou é uma cola Seca tem qualquer coisa
aqui no Talvez o cabelo dela mas quando
alguma coisa eu não sei se brigar com um
bocado o cabelo mas vejo com vocês
pessoal comenta embaixo O que que você
espera que ele
sim ou não
E aí
Ah tá
e olha isso tem muita sujidade
isto Parece que foi colado com umas
ligaduras molhadas com cola qualquer
coisa assim que parece ser muito mais
ligaduras
e cheira muito mal visto sempre serão
aulas de cabeça olha só
e olha aí estranho já está me convenci a
parte hahaha é a parte da frente umas
coisas brancas é como se fosse bolor
apodreceu esta boneca
E aí meu rei como é que se diz é que os
olhos dela mexe meu Olha isso ela quando
deita os olhos fecham e quando levantou
os olhos abrem sinistro ok aqui dentro
nós conseguimos ver um canismo como se
eu sou um animatronic
e olha aí
e dá para ver
ok Aqui tem este pelo que é como se
fosse uma limpeza não é que é o que faz
com os olhos fecha e quando ela se deita
e a vão quando ela se levanta Ok é um
cadinho bem simples Até a cabeça parece
uma mim que nunca foi aberta com podem
ver aqui nota-se que há uma união mas é
de origem pode ser colocar esse elástico
eu tenho colocar um novo elástico aqui
naquele ferro atrás e ela vai aprender
precisamente assim
o plástico tem que estar bem
se não funcionar porque a medida que eu
ando com a boneca ela Teoricamente faz
isto
o presente estudo paga já tá
e olha
não eu já não dormi aqui hoje vou dormir
na rua é mais seguro
E aí
o
fracasso elétron pessoa
não sabemos agora aquela bela meu Deus
ok aqui não parece ter mais nada só
tenho aqui este velcro e por esta
Sebastião tapete vermelho tem qualquer
coisa aqui o Calma lá está colado com
cola quente será que alguma coisa
embaixo
E aí
eu não sei eu consegui descolar
Eu acho que eu te falo até o fim escola
eu não sei para ter alguma coisa ali eu
não quero ver eu tenho neste momento
documento porque só me faltava dela e
tem qualquer coisa escrita nela ainda
por cima é para uma coisa escrito ali
Amy
Amy Amy Amy
eu disse MM
qualquer coisa me explica eu tô com nojo
olha
brincar uma coisa boneca
coisa de macumba e é
Oi
Bella tudo mais medo dela me atende
Sempre ela e a galinha morta
a estrada encontra os meus dessas coisas
Não
do mato assim um balde assim como a
galinha como pata de galinha com velas e
juro que tenham nunca juro te juro que
tem says
E assim se tivermos
Tô
sim nega dela mesmo
E aí
e tem qualquer coisa que está aqui mesmo
em mim
a Emily é
o e-mail
e a Emily Emily Emily
Emily é uma mulher linda
E aí mãe só que ela
E aí
e tem aqui mais uma coisa né
o que é que um triângulo
tem 1519 né
e parece um 1919 que anos de idade será
é completamente arrepiado pessoal Será
que era uma jovem com 19 anos chamada a
Emily
eu
juro só estou fascinado com isto já
valeu a pena ter comprado esta caixa
justamente incrível e eu desaprovo essa
ideia não não isso claramente tipo
Pronto tem aqui todo um suspense alguém
construir de forma que nossa imaginação
as coisas obviamente que não tem nada
aqui com a macumba de tudo mais espero
eu tu és sempre tão sem Olá eu sou
cético até acontecer algo ainda não
aconteceu nada porque não é só uma
tarefa simples
[Aplausos]
O
que acontecerá continuar aqui para o
canal aqui vai estar bem falou que
quando
E aí essa pessoa a comentar a Dark
Stephen meu eu tô Ana Luisa tudo que eu
estou a ver eu não posso enviar
É não pô
e
foi queimada Ok e tem que mudou também
velas pegam Moro Eu nunca vi uma vela
como valor mínimo estranho né ou Apple
pode ser só não
É
sim tinha há tanto tempo ela foi com
aquela mesa é
o meu Emily será o nome dela pessoal
comentem o que vocês acham ajudem-me a
investigar se existe alguma boneca
chamada
lo-19 pode ser uma referência idade pode
ser uma referência ao ano pode ser uma
referência
e aos dias para os dias e se for uma
referência ao tempo de vida que me resta
depois num tantas vezes Cala a boca Vá é
tipo também também se a boca né
e ela vai ajudar essa voz misteriosa
caminha chegar olha aí que eu posto já
não descansa bem pensar nisso
a Anna burra pa
Oi vó
e também 19 foi
e essas coisas assim também
Não
esquece a idade dela ela problema é
Oi Marcela
e vamos tentar usar a caneca pessoal eu
rivel Desculpa pessoal esta é a boneca é
mamãe é
e
é muito melhor
pessoalmente aí vocês querem que eu faça
mais vídeos com esta mulher qualquer eu
até poderia montar as armas o que disse
alguns comportamentos Preciso comprar
elástico de quatro para ela precisa
juntar aqui algumas coisas para
conseguir limpar lá e restaurá-la e tudo
mais e e tensão também abrir a boneca e
nesta Caixa de Música funciona ou não
mas só vou fazer isso que só que nós
conseguimos chegar pelo menos aos 20 mil
like aqui nesse vídeo ok eu sei que
vocês conseguem se quiserem ter mais
vídeos neste gênero com essa boneca eu
sei que vocês vão deixar like aqui nesse
vídeo eu vou saber se posso continuar ou
não e outra coisa eu encomendei
eu encomendei
i i i f Bieber ou seja um detector de
fantasmas Eu não vou testá-lo agora ok
Porque eu já fui demasiada de estar com
esta vela porque nós temos aqui o nome
temos um número eu não sei se a idade
delas é o nome dela no Face ainda vou
investigar Ok mas temos aqui um detector
de fantasmas que funciona por
eletromagnetismo e não sei se vocês
quiserem que eu tento encontrar aqui
alguma coisa se sente ver se ela está
possuída não a própria caixa comentem
também Deixei muito like nós temos aqui
uma data de coisas para fazer com esta
boneca Então é só comentar as vossas
ideias que só e é isso espero que a
gente está aqui deste vídeo fiquem bem e
até a próxima